Well, there's no question that the
opioid epidemic is evolving.
So now we have most of our overdose deaths
from heroin and fentanyl,
and those deaths unfortunately are
increasing, but we do know that there are
strategies in place to address some of
these issues.
We have more focus on treatment, which
is really what we need right now,
we need to make sure those folks who have an opioid use disorder
who have an addiction, have access to treatment.
When you talk about revaluation
and the options and alternatives to treat pain,
that requires everyone. So, again, we have to make sure that insurers pay for those alternatives.
For instance, physical therapy may be helpful, but does a patient have access
to that if it's an increased copay for
physical therapy versus a prescription?
And what about paid time off?
So doctors are certainly and have always been
willing to make treatment recommendations,
but it's important to make sure that those
alternatives are available.
So I think we have everyone from the FDA looking at this. People are looking at maybe
non-addictive alternatives to treat pain.
I can tell you that I am a part of a task force at NIH
where there's a research paradigm going forward looking at alternatives to treat pain.
So everyone is working together to make sure that
there are alternatives to treat pain.
However, we want to make sure that
those who are doing well, taking their meds as prescribed, and have never misused
their opioid prescriptions, still
have access to that medication.
Every state has a registry, and each
state has a different law,
but for the most part, this is a database. So let me just say as a physician, I prescribe an opioid.
I first of all go in and check that database
to see if anyone else has prescribed
another opioid recently,  or a medication where there may be a negative side effect from that.
So it really is a tool in the toolbox for our physicians.
And so that is kept in a database, and physicians again can check it to see what other medications
the patient's on, and to see if there might be a need to have a discussion with the patient.
One of the things we have to be careful of regarding this database
or anything else --
that we don't judge and that we have
conversations with the patients.
So these databases really are alternatives.
"I see that here on anti-anxiety medication, and you're also on this opioid medication....Let's talk about the fact that that could be a deadly combination."
The databases are important, but they're not a panacea.
I will also say that we want to make sure
that we want to make sure that these databases are kept in
public health departments.
Again these databases should be used as a tool.
We also mentioned about the national database,
and so what's very important is
that there already is an agency, the
National Association of Boards of Pharmacy,
that can link, I believe, 48 of the states already.
So if I'm here in Georgia,
and I'm practicing maybe near the border,
I can have access,
if that state has decided to participate
in that, to information around Georgia, to Florida,
Kentucky and so forth.
I have to say these databases are just
for controlled substances, so each state
might have a different list of medications,
but mainly it's about either
opioids or about benzo-based, so mainly
controlled substances in that particular database.
Alcohol and opioids do not mix,
but let's just take this back a step.
It's important to have conversations about risk factors
for a substance use disorder as a general part
of our practices, and particularly, again,
when prescribing an opioid.
The AMA is encouraging physicians to do a
risk assessment, including the past history
of problems with other drugs,
medications, misusing other medications.
So that's a part of the overall evaluation and questions,
and physicians ask before they prescribed an opioid.
So, again, we really need more research
to make sure that we can offer
evidence-based alternatives to pain. Everyone may think they have a good idea, but really
these ideas have to be studied,
and of course, that's what we do as physicians
regarding evidence-based treatment.
But here is some we know right now --
we know that some folks are relieved
by physical therapy, but you know what, a surgery
might be an option.
We have pain specialists who offer nerve blocks,
so there could be interventional
alternatives,
there could be other medications
that work, that are not opioids.
It could be biofeedback and, again, physical therapy.
And so all of these alternatives are available now.
It's important that we have a research agenda from the national perspective
to identify additional alternatives, non opioid alternatives.
But even if an alternative exists today,
if a patient cannot afford, it, either
because they have a high copay,
or it requires more time of from work,
or don't have any insurance at all,
we really have not provided  the access.
We really have to work on that.